au jour d'aujourd'hui on a relevé 15 cas
depuis dimanche de la notification du à
la nature ans et qu'on nous avait eu
connaissance du premier cas
d'intoxication nous avons tout de suite
fait un communiqué de presse le 4
février et nous avons nous sommes tout
de suite intervenus chez tous les
clients tous les clients distributeurs
du grossiste en entier qui avait
commercialisé ces produits
on a vérifié que les produits étaient
bien retirer du marché les que
l'affichage de rappel était bien en
rayon et dans le cas échéant s'ils
n'étaient pas on a procédé on a fait
procéder à ces mesures il ya environ
combien de paquets qui de qui étaient en
circulation
alors
ce sont en gros il ya peu près 150
paquet qui ont été commercialisés et on
aurait retiré du marché
plus de la moitié pour l'instant il ya
encore dix ans encore des départs le
coeur des paquets en circulation alors
que je peux pas vous dire exactement
combien mai
on a retiré quand j'étais plus de la
moitié à peu près 80 qui ont été retirés
des chats a eu plusieurs lots de
contaminer le fabricant nous a
communiqué une liste de lots
susceptibles d'être contaminés il ya une
première
en 10 ans fin des soldes 21 décembre
sont intervenus auprès du grossiste en
martinique commercialiser les pro s'est
produit nous avons initié une procédure
de retrait rappel donc les lots c'était
dans le dos mais moi je les ai marqué la
183 10 889 10 880 19 18 215 18
donc ça n 316 18 ça c'était les premiers
à notre première intervention on descend
on n'a ni si le retrait rappel vu que
les produits ont été retirés du marché
qui a pas d'oxydation n'a pas fait de
communication sur nos actions voilà
alors suite à notre passage en fait qui
se trouve que lorsqu'on est passé enfin
lorsqu'on est intervenu auprès du
grossiste en martinique il avait la
marchandises en transit et lorsqu'il a
reçu cette marchandise
il a remis sur le marché donc les lots
qui était présent lors de notre
intervention avait été retiré mais il ya
ce conteneur qui est arrivé après donc
c'est ce qu'on voit là dans le lot qui
pose problème mais le lot 316 18 qui a
été reçue après notre intervention du 21
décembre
d'accord il s'agit de quoi exactement
est de quel mal ce n'est pas uniquement
commercialisée en maison diot n'ont pas
uniquement maison des produits sont
commercialisés en grande distribution
classique